there's no time
[Music]
it's us again yep we're still here it's
friday
all right and we started drinking yeah
looks like everybody's here pretty much
got a nice crowd in there
taylor's there what's up t mango badger
sophie's in there he said she's not sure
she'll stay the whole time yeah we don't
know how long it is
it's gonna go on how long is this gonna
go on
baby june's in there david i got the uh
i got the blu-rays you sent man
thank you very much i'm very excited yes
man the thanks killing one is like it's
a big
it's like that big man that's like a
special edition yeah i'm excited to
delve into that
i don't think i've seen thanksgiving
actually we've seen times
again we're going to review tusk uh
pretty soon
yeah yes we should definitely do that
yeah but thanksgiving will probably
we might save that for thanksgiving
thanksgiving show
we'll see you know what i mean we'll see
we'll just see how it goes because we
don't have a lot of thanksgiving there
aren't a lot of thanksgiving themed
horror movies
although hulu does those um
what do they call that [ __ ] they they
have like a series called into the dark
and they make a money they make a money
they make they make it a money
they make a movie like every month
that has to do with whatever holidays
that month and some of them remember i'm
pretty good
that was remember the the uh one we did
that was called puka
that was their christmas one one year we
i still haven't watched the sequel to
that
like puka lives alfred that was the one
with the damn monster right
well with the guy in the suit remember
too yeah let's do that [ __ ] creepy
suit i really liked that movie
but yeah i think um yeah they did uh
they did a sequel but i haven't watched
it yet i think hula's got that too
yeah we uh went down had to go uh
we had to go to mannequins to see big
tom
meet up with the girl that jenny did a
job for and while we were down there
we went to chantal's which is in the
daytime day time
we've never been in the daytime but
usually we just go and we're drunk as
[ __ ] at 3 o'clock in the morning yeah
and they had
normally at night they have their
abbreviated uh menu
we were there for the full menu and uh
man it was good i still had i had the
chicken and waffles
which was good uh but jenny ordered the
grand slam
it was uh it was basically
cajun shrimp and grits with catfish
god man i wish i had gotten that it was
so much food though that i had to help
her finish it
yeah i couldn't finish it yeah well as
soon as i well the thing about it okay
so i knew that we had to go down to
downtown sanford today because i had to
like have a meeting with that girl
and like i said i was meeting her at
mannequins and chantal's is like
two doors down from there i was like
well we might as well both go down there
and
you know and then we'll eat at chantals
we've never eaten there during the day
and uh you know so like like i said at
night they're open till four in the
morning
that's what they said today so they just
have like this one little card that has
maybe like five or six things on it like
fish and chips like easy [ __ ] you know
and um but as soon as i opened their
full menu and saw shrimp and grits on
there i'm like no i'm having that
but i didn't realize um because she said
well you can get the option where it
comes with some fried fish
too and i was like yeah why not and she
brought the plate out
and i was like what if i got myself into
it it's massive
this is this massive it was so good and
it actually it had like sauteed
vegetables in it too like
onions and uh bell peppers oh man it was
delicious
yeah so we missed chantal we were
hanging out with her she's nice she's
probably a couple years younger than us
probably huh she looks like yeah right
around
around our same age she was uh took me
out back and showed me her motorcycle
she's got like four harleys and stuff
she had one of them where they're full
dressers
she's uh rides bikes and uh
she's uh she's pretty cool and we were
talking about the menu
i had got some of that nana pudding from
her it was good really yeah that's right
you got nana
yeah for dessert there was no way i
wanted some dessert they make really
really good red velvet cake
um and they have carrot cake too and
i've been want to try that but it's just
like i couldn't even finish
like my lunch so he had to eat some of
it yeah
she rides and stuff we had fun fun
talking
yeah we were talking about yeah we hung
out there a long time yeah we told her
we told her about pokemon tell everybody
yeah you guys
i actually get a shirt that says that
let me tell you about my cat yeah
i think she had her daughters there
working wasn't her daughter maybe that
waited on us oh i don't know
i'm not sure i'm not sure but um that
was a you know what's funny this is what
a small [ __ ] town this is
yeah the woman that was uh the waitress
yeah that's right so it wasn't
yeah it was like um she was like i know
you guys you guys look really familiar
and i said well we've been in here
before but only in the middle of the
night and she said i don't work in the
middle of the night
and she said oh she's like did you used
to go in the sam's liquor store you're
like yeah and i was like yeah we used to
go to the sam's liquor store
and she's like i used to work that i was
like oh yeah i thought you looked
familiar
she knew us from the liquor store what
did that say
yeah about our life choices
[Laughter]
so chantal got our all of our little
links and stuff she said she's gonna be
watching the show she's gonna be
stalking us
yeah well she invited us to uh um stream
from
from chantal's if we wanted to they're
good because there's a dj booth there
and everything
we'll see i mean everybody's asking us
it's so it's just so much more
convenient to stream from the house here
well yeah because i have all my [ __ ]
here
all the shit's here right you know how
lazy i am and i'm just kind of like well
it's not so much laziness it's just like
once i have everything set up
the way i want to it's like if i have to
move it i'm like
because i can just imagine all the
things that will go wrong because i'm
sure it will
yeah um you know what i mean so it's
like i like the idea
it's just the thought of doing it just
makes me tired but i don't know we'll
see
jenny took a picture of the damn plate
both of what we got you posted that on
instagram i think didn't you yes
yeah i'm gonna look i'm gonna cut some
videos down there next time i go on a
ride i'll [ __ ] uh ride by there if i
could take some videos and put them up
on yeah you should because you went down
there though yeah i go down there that's
just like a good
ride yeah downtown sanford is actually
pretty cool it's tiny it's only like a
few blocks
but it's actually really cool it's got
like a lot of really cool bars really
cool
restaurants like a lot of german
restaurants for whatever yeah
the mexican restaurant across from
mannequins i want to try yeah little uh
antique shops tons of those like little
already like art galleries stuff like
that
it's really really small it's kind of
like downtown deland is kind of like
that too yeah
but more of a college kind of vibe and
see what everybody's doing but yeah it's
super super fun
you're still piling in everybody's pile
in
room for everybody
[Laughter]
but yeah so that was a super fun day
yeah man that shrimp and grits was so
[ __ ] good
right she had a good kind of cajun
seasoning
on the shrimp oh yeah like a buttery
type gravy with it and it mixed in with
the grits and cheese real well
yeah because the grits had cheese on
them too yeah of course the um
tony said uh esther said tom and jenny
the blu-ray dvd death valley should come
to you wednesday
all right thanks esther that's sweet i
didn't know death valley yeah i don't
know that one
i know i don't think i've seen it either
yeah they're saying it's a great film
i forgot it sounds familiar isn't that
the one that has the kid that was in a
christmas story
yeah i think so yeah tina goes nana
putting his
divine yeah and see
me and chantals were getting into it
about cooking
she pointed out it says you can't use
any generic vanilla wafers with the vive
and
we were like no no it's got to be
vanilla the nabisco one yeah the nabisco
ones and
and she did something a little bit
different with she she added a slight uh
amount of cinnamon to it which gave it a
a a different
a different uh element that i never had
before i liked it it was really good i
would do that
i'm pretty sure when my grandma made it
i think she's put cinnamon in it yeah
but like i said i don't like bananas so
i never eat it when my grandma made it
yeah when my grandmother made it she was
no cinnamon it was just plain
yeah it was good but it was just plain
like that outside but with that
slight hint of cinnamon it mixed with
those cookies real well yeah
and it kind of had a more like a graham
cracker crust
effect in a way you know what i mean
there's something about i liked it it
was good
i'd do that and then we were talking
about
i said so that catfish needs to come
with something i said how about just
some ketchup and she's like i don't know
what i'm going to be rum a lot
and i was thinking about i didn't really
think about it at the time but
she's probably never had homemade
ketchup go down there and [ __ ] make
her some ketchup
especially like jack daniel's ketchup oh
yeah
that'd be real but the thing is is that
whenever we got catfish we caught it
ourselves
yeah all right well she said she sources
the catfish
from a dude that catches them locally at
sanford and you can catch it yourself
and then when you when you're making it
at home you're just going to use what's
in the refrigerator you have
you know ketchup that's what we used i
liked it better than tartar sauce
better than even um cocktail sauce
because that sweetness going in with the
batter with the cornmeal the cornmeal
batter on the on on the fish
it's just it offsets one another that
sweet and saltiness i liked it
but uh somebody just read super chat
thank you gadgey3
what do you say cause i fell asleep on
friday again hard week
yeah i know we've all been there sandra
was asking um
what do they serve in german restaurants
because well no i well i've looked on
like there's
several german restaurants down there i
think hollerbox is probably the best
known one it's like really really big
um and there's a couple other ones too
and there's like some breweries and
whatnot
they have yeah they have like a lot of
um like currywurst
they have sauerbratten they have
um what the [ __ ] else do they have what
are some other germline try a lot of
beer
yeah a lot of beer um they have like
everything looked
cabbage um schnitzel that's kind of
their that's their specialty
actually i've never eaten there i ate it
they have like a um i don't know if
they're
associated i think they are because i
think it's called hollerbox willow tree
and then there's a little deli around
the corner which is like a separate
thing and i think that's just called
willow tree i've eaten there before
and they make um like sandwiches and
[ __ ] like that
and i've eaten there before and that was
that's really really good but that's
just more like
that's more like a deli counter you just
go up and order a sandwich and get chips
within one nut
and like dessert in america german food
is usually just pork chops sauerkraut
and mustard
and boiled potatoes but holler boxes
they have a really extensive
yeah i mean like i said they have all
different kinds of schnitzel they have
all different kinds of
uh they have bratwurst they have
currywurst they have all different kind
of stuff so it's i think it's actually
owned by germans
so i mean every time i go past there and
it's a
massive place every time i go past there
it's always [ __ ] packed
and there's there's people sitting
inside and there's people sitting at
they have a big huge patio around the
outside and there's tons of people
sitting out there too
and for some reason too there's a big uh
beer culture down there
hopefully oh my god did we freeze up
already at 17 [ __ ] minutes no it's
still it's still going on my
on my tablet this better not be doing
this look at that
that shit's doing its [ __ ] this better
not be just not yours come on come on
come on the stream's fine here you can
do it
i'm gonna be really mad hey guys love
your topics
i know about everything uh you shouldn't
know about amelia earhart except where
she is
i've researched everything i can get my
hands on for the past 40 years hey
everybody and then there yeah everything
i
everybody says that we're good on their
end i mean it's just kind of it just
froze up on
jenny's screen for some reason why is
your [ __ ] doing this
i don't know what are you asking me for
i didn't do it i didn't build this [ __ ]
it's it's back now yeah but you know
it's just hopefully it will not
just don't move around too much if
you're just like i'm gonna overload i'm
gonna over yes
[Laughter]
i don't know how much that helps but i'm
just gonna like just don't move
like don't wave your hands around don't
do anything yeah it's like
just i don't know it's not gonna matter
it's gonna do it or it's not gonna
well i know but it's i don't know it's
just it keeps bothering me all the time
yeah um everything you know what another
super chat
oh did we okay so i'm behind says yeah
you're behind
yeah i'm behind esther says because your
caregiving is hard
yeah gave us ten dollars thank you very
much thank you thank you very much thank
you
that's awesome i wonder why it's not
showing up well that's what happens
yeah it lags that's why i'm worried
because i don't want it to [ __ ] stop
again but i'm just gonna keep on
i mean sometimes if you just like try
and power through it
then it'll come back you know what else
is funny is that the comments
are all out of order on yours you're in
a different order than mine are
well i don't know what to tell you yeah
weird
because they're in there talking about
sausage and all kinds of stuff
well i see that because we were talking
about the restaurant
but yeah they have they had a bunch of
like i just looked at the menu real
quick earlier and i was just kind of
because i was curious